foreign
this case is important because the
Supreme Court has called schools
nurseries of democracy we expect our
public schools to prepare the next
generation of Americans and it has been
part of American culture since the
founding to criticize and satirize those
in power and it teaches a very dangerous
lesson to kids about what America and
our constitution is about if they're
taught from a young age that if they
criticize or satirize somebody in power
that they can get in trouble for it that
is not what the first amendment is about
and it is not what the Constitution is
about
my name is Connor Fitzpatrick I am an
attorney at the foundation for
individual rights and expression so last
year a high school student at Tullahoma
High School posted three memes on his
personal Instagram page satirizing the
principle the memes were very tame they
did not threaten anyone they did not
contain any bad words but what they did
do is poke fun at the principal's overly
serious nature the first meme showed the
principal holding a box of vegetables
the second showed the principle uh in a
dress with cat whiskers and cat ears and
the third show the principal being
hugged by a cartoon bird and in
retaliation for posting those memes the
school suspended the student for three
days and that's a violation of the First
Amendment
the school claimed to be relying on a
student policy that prohibits students
from posting anything online which
embarrasses demeans or discredits
someone else but the problem with that
is posting content which embarrasses or
discredits a government official is
protected by the First Amendment it has
been for over 200 years and more than
that it's a vague policy a video of the
high school quarterback throwing an
interception might embarrass or
discredit them surely the school isn't
going to prohibit that and the danger
with vague policies is that those in
power use it to suppress criticism
there are two primary Supreme Court
cases that will govern this case the
first is Tinker versus Des Moines from
the late 1960s Tinker involved middle
middle school students who wanted to
wear black armbands to school to protest
the Vietnam War and the Supreme Court
held that as long as a student's
expression does not substantially
disrupt the school day the first
amendment protects their right to make
their voices heard
and the second case that governs this
particular dispute is a case called
mahanoi and it's from 2021. that dealt
with a Snapchat post by a high school
student who was unhappy that she didn't
make the varsity cheerleading team and
when she didn't she posted a couple of
snaps to Snapchat uh saying a few bad
words about the cheerleading team and
the school and what the Supreme Court
held is that based on Tinker because her
Snapchats did not cause any disruption
at school the school had no business
punishing her for her private expression
on her own time and that's the case here
the student posted these Instagram memes
on his own time two of them during
summer vacation away from school and
they did not disrupt School
in order for a school to be able to
punish a student for their expression it
has to meet a very high bar it has to
substantially disrupt the school day and
the cases that have interpreted that
standard have found that what's
necessary is something like a direct
threat or sexual threat against another
teacher or another student something
that tangibly impacts the school day or
could tangibly impact the school day in
a severe manner like threatening the
school's safety like threatening
violence nothing like that is present
here these are peaceful playful
Instagram means memes showing the
principle holding vegetables and being
hugged by a cartoon bird they aren't
threats they're nowhere near what courts
have held is required in order for the
school to censor it we feel comfortable
that these memes are squarely protected
by the First Amendment because they
occurred outside of Campus did not
disrupt the school day and the school
has never claimed otherwise